so hey everybody thank you all for
coming I hope that you grab the beer and
pizza and you enjoyed it and today we're
going to talk about deep analysis of
quick stream now first allow me to
introduce myself my name is Sega valve
I'm a data scientist here at similarweb
part of the amazing data analysis group
I'm currently now live in Tel Aviv after
many many years or too many years in the
Technion where most of my focus was on
computer vision the classic one machine
learning and I dealt in my career also
in the deep learning and now with NLP so
a bit about what we're gonna do today so
I not told you about similar web server
already know so I'm just going to talk
about some problems that we are facing
regarding the privacy in the digital
world and how looking at URLs of the
language actually helped us to tackle it
and get even more insights that allow us
to classify the web traffic and
eventually we're gonna do a short
summary of everything so privacy in the
digital world now I'm sure that you all
we're about the GDP are the new data
policy the data privacy regulations that
came last May and I'm sure that you all
see a lot of terms update and data
policy updates from the various products
that you are using now this is really
reshape the way that we the data is
handled around the around the internet
and similar web as being a GDP are
compliant company will continue to
ensure that our users privacy is
protected and no personal information is
being used now in our world it means
that the clickstream our data mustn't
contain any PII is in our URLs now a PII
is a personally identifiable information
actually information in the URL that can
lead back to a specific user here you
can see some examples of PII so for
example the first link this is the URL
to my LinkedIn profile you can see my
name and surname now if it will click on
it you will get to my social to my
social media page and you will actually
have access to a lot of information
about myself making me not anonymous
anymore the Facebook if you will click
on that link you get the Facebook ID
over here
and if you would click on it you will
get to a Facebook image this is Mark
Zuckerberg profile page and again now we
have access to all of its profile which
again is no longer anonymous and we said
that we can't use and we're not using
any URLs that contain any personal
information this is not what we care
about so we want to say that gdpr
compliant now as you can see some
parameters are really identifying what's
happening here right the email name and
surname so current or is the current
method some method use rule-based
heuristics in order to find those pis
but those parameters are constantly
changing especially in the dynamic world
of the URLs so we wanted to see if we
can extract more information from the
URL itself in order to tackle this
problem so we move forward to look at
URLs as a language now what can we learn
from URLs unlike traditional languages
URLs lack the semantics grammar and
clear separation to part of speech right
in language we have noun verbs
adjectives and the URLs it's not so
clear but actually URLs do serve as kind
of protocol for transferring information
around the web right so it actually is
kind of a language so maybe we can get
an americorps presentation of that URL
after any splitting into words or
somehow and while getting that numeric
representation we can apply any NLP
techniques on it in order to proper
classify in this case the PII that we've
seen in the URLs so now in order to do
that I'm just going to do a quick review
on what is the generic NLP flow which
I'm sure that you all know right usually
we have our corpus right here it's three
sentences PI that arranges awesome
meetups meetups are cool and cool
meetups are pilot a specialty right all
right great now in our case it's just
going to be millions over millions of
URLs that we need to build the corpus
from them right so the next stage
usually is going to be building the
vocabulary the vocabulary is just a
simple mapping between each unique word
from the corpus to an index right so
this is the first stage of getting the
numeric representation of our URLs so
the next step is just going to be an
Hillary step map each of the sentences
to the set of the indices that composes
the sentence right so pi data i'm
getting i'm going to the vocabulary it's
ID number one so I'm putting wander and
meetups number four and so on you got
the point right so how I'm actually
getting the the numerical presentation
so I'm going to use something that you
all know this is the embedding matrix
now an embedding matrix is just a matrix
that map's for each word in a vocabulary
a vector in the size of K that is that
represent this is the numeric
representation so now for example pi
data which is mapped to ID number one
it's represented by the kalyan vector in
the first column of the matrix awesome
is represented by the vector in the
third column is that clear right we all
know that so usually this is either
randomly initialized or we can use any
one hot encoding or if we have any pre
trained word embeddings like we're two
vector will use them now in our case
we're talking about URL something that
we haven't seen before and doesn't
possess any pre trained word embeddings
and this is actually it's an very
important intermediate because this is
constantly updating during training the
model write the vectors are being
updated to get a more meaningful
representation of the words so the last
step is just going from the indexing
part and get a numeric representation
for each sentence so vector number 2
arranges I'm going to column number 2
maps it to the K line vector and now I
have an americorps presentation for each
of the sentences so how can we apply it
on your ELLs so let's say that we have
this Wikipedia page and I want to get a
numerical presentation for it
so if in the normal language we would
split or tokenize the URL by the
sentence by commas spaces and dots here
I'm going to here I can do actually
tokenization by special characters dots
back slashes questions marks question
mark and so on and I'm actually getting
the words that composes this sentence or
the URL in comparison now if I if I will
do it on all the URLs on
all of my corporate can actually
construct my vocabulary right and I have
that vocabulary I can get the word ID
for each one of those of those words and
again I constructed already an embedding
metrics in the size of the vocabulary
which is now randomly initialized I can
get a corresponding vector for each one
of the word IDs and eventually I'm
getting metrics representation of that
URL which can now I can use any data any
statistic tool on top of it to do any
kind of classification Tech ossification
tasks or any NLP problems so let's talk
about a bit NLP and its pros and cons
now classical approaches for Texas if
ocation like bag of word or extracting
any lexical features have many drawbacks
the first one is that usually we have
too many words in our vocabulary which
can result in memory constraints while
we train the model and getting the world
embedding especially in our world in the
URLs when we have thousands of thousands
newer new URLs every day and in multiple
languages keeping such metrics is not
feasible right because we're gonna need
a constant size matrix which can't
happen here now the second problem is
new word at test time I can only obtain
word embeddings for words that I've seen
before that they actually have been in
my vocabulary so infrequent words or new
words the test time actually get the
unknown token which I'm sure that you
some of you actually heard of it a word
that you haven't seen before you cannot
get the embedding for it and it usually
requires expert feature engineering and
language we got linguistics to help us
construct those features in URLs we can
think about statistical features like
the length of the URL the number of dot
ins the number of dots in the URL and
the length of every segment in the URL
which can be very time-consuming on the
other hand convolutional neural Nets
every I'm sure recently recently shown
promising performance on text
classification and I want to talk about
one in particular so this is URL that
URL net is a CNN based model for
malicious URL detection it's a paper and
a work done by Anglia tale' at the
University of Singapore it actually
repairs
URL using two branches the world level
embedding and the character level
embedding getting the representation
from each branch and actually apply CNN
on every on each one of them and
eventually they are combined into one
now let me dive further into this so
let's say that I have M words in my
vocabulary so I have the corpus of the
URLs ad tokenization by special
characters and eventually I have M words
in the vocabulary and I have C unique
characters now C is finite right you
have the ABC you have dots backslash is
question marks all the characters that
composes URLs and let's say that I want
to represent each word or character in a
vector of length K again this K is a
hyper parameter that can actually be
changed after so what you are on a does
it represent the URL in two different
branches the character level or the
character branch takes the URL split it
into characters right we have C number
of characters get the vector that get
the corresponding vector that represent
the character and eventually we will
have a matrix representation that will
represent the URL in the character level
now in order to do that we need the
first embedding matrix the character
embedding matrix that map's each each
character to a Kalin's vector and I'm
gonna show a bit of what I mean what I
meant so let's say amazon.com right so
the first step will be split the URL
into characters so into characters now I
can go and get their character ID this
is the auxilary stage that we talked
about and once I have the character ID I
can go to the embedding matrix the
character embedding matrix and get the
corresponding vector for each character
right so now I have a matrix
representation of the URL in the
character level this is after followed
by convolutional layers and we can see
that we're actually trying to find
relationships between different
characters in the URL right which is
usually very is very helpful but what it
ignores
the word boundaries right it actually
also tried to find your relationship
between characters from different words
this w and that am are not necessarily
connected to each other so the paper
offers a second branch which is the word
which is the word level representation
that will only look at at the word level
and actually not ignores it will ignores
though not gonna ignore those dots and
the separation so the second branch as I
say the word level we've seen it before
you're taking the URL split it lead to
the words and get a representation for
each word so this requires the word
embedding metrics that map's each word
into the corresponding vector now we
said it start actually that word level
embeddings they have a lot of drawbacks
right
I can't infer any new words and test
time and if the vocabulary is so big I
cannot manage with this matrix so the
paper offers the third and final
representation matrix that also maps
characters to embedding vectors but this
characters is different representation
from the first matrix because this
characters only talks about characters
that are being in the same word only
characters that are used in words
together will be will be learned here
and I will show an example in a sec I
just want to emphasize that those three
matrix are randomly in those two
matrices are randomly initialized right
and they're gonna change they're gonna
update during training using using the
back prop so the backdrop of this net
will also update the weights of the
filters of the count layers and will
also update the embedding matrices here
and by that we're going to get a more
meaningful representation for each
character or word so the world level is
actually constructed from two different
areas so if I want to represent HTTP for
example the most direct approach will go
as we've seen before get the word ID and
get the corresponding vector from the
word embedding matrix so now I have a K
length vector that represented now I can
do I can go even further more and I can
split that word into the character that
composes it
get the character ID and then go to the
embed the character embedding metrics
that find relationships between
characters within the same word and get
the corresponding vectors so now on the
right actually I have a matrix or
presentation of the word in its
character level is that clear so if I
want to enjoy both of these worlds I can
do a quick summation right I'm gonna sum
on the on some axis of that matrix
element wise summing those two vectors
from the word embedding and the
character embedding and eventually this
is the word embedding that I'm getting
from that word it's constructed from
both character level and word level so
this is done for one word from the URL
so URL itself will give us a matrix
right so on top of that we can use as we
said convolutional filters and I want to
show you some some results Oh what about
words that we haven't seen before right
this is the problem that you want to
tackle so let's say that I'm the time
tackling the world iPhone access now six
months ago iPhone access as the word
around the web didn't existed so if I
would try to get an embedding for that
word I would go to the to my vocabulary
I would get the unknown token right I
didn't see it six months ago so now we
found if I want to obtain an embedding
for it it's gonna be problematic so this
is where the character level come at
hand I can split the iPhone access into
the characters that composes it get the
characters ID which I always have
because it's finite numbers of
characters and I can get a matrix
representation for iPhone access again
after summation I get the word embedding
a vector embedding for new words that I
haven't seen before so this is how it
actually solved that problem of
infrequent words that usually we ignore
because of the size of the vocabulary
and new words that I haven't seen before
it all at test time so I want to show
you some results of their paper so this
is the URL net architecture you can see
the first two layers are the embedding
layers that we just talked about
thoroughly those are followed by
convolutional layers and fully connected
layers which I'm not going to elaborate
on because I think that we were well we
are aware about them and I remind you
that their task was to proper testify
between malicious urls and non malicious
urls so they actually train their model
took a vector representation from the
last layer of the architecture and this
is the projection of the urls that of
the results that they got now we can see
a clear separation this is a really nice
results we can see clear separation
between the non-malicious urls on the
left in green and malicious urls in red
now moreover you can see that there are
a bit of clusters around the image so
actually let's say that URLs that have
Google as a main domain are in one
cluster at the top at the bottom left
and URL that have zip file extension are
in different clusters which is really
interesting because we can see that the
URL not actually learned and what to
emphasize from the from the URL and what
and it learned the proper presentation
so we said well that's great now how can
we use it remember we said that we need
to find PII is right we need to find in
the URLs something that can lead back to
the user so actually we took that URL
net and we retrained it with now the new
objective of either the URL possess API
information or doesn't have any PII
information on it so we actually use two
million URLs and the URLs had PII is in
the forms of emails locations zip codes
and so on and we actually got 97%
accuracy which for us was really
impressive but moreover we actually
found PII is in URLs that weren't found
during the rule based heuristics you can
see here that we have the name surname
and nickname of two users from two big
social media from two big social you
don't see it in the back trust me
the URL 0 with name surname inside
them that were found in the that the
current rule based heuristics didn't
find now this is really great so we can
we could actually generalize and find
new parameters and the new new
combination of characters in the new
data set of the URLs that were fighting
the current heuristics so it's well it
was really interesting for us but it was
one task we actually wanted to expand
the usage of URL not for some other use
cases and I want to take you to the
second use case which is traffic from
sponsored links companies and industries
around the internet really care about
measuring how much sponsored traffic
they're they're getting and their
competitors getting this is how they
measure their efficiency of the
efficiency of their online campaigns now
any one of you that did any marketing
research result recently knows that URL
actually possessed some parameters that
can indicate whether the link and
sponsored or not like UTM source or UTM
campaign are parameters that indicate
yes this link is sponsored but actually
any company can decide that it can't
that it will use different parameters
new parameters that haven't seen before
so we wanted to see if we can actually
generalize and learn new parameters
right a parameter that that never seen
before so we we wanted to use URL net to
find those indicating parameters so
again we took the URL net we retrained
it and by retraining I remind you that
the embedding matrices are changing
according to the task before that the
embedding was corresponding four pís and
before that it was for malicious URLs
now the character level and the world
level embedding will be different
because they are the the backdrop it's
according to the to the problem and
according to the data so we retrain the
URL net to find whether the link is
sponsored or not and we did a projection
of our results and this is quite
interesting we see that the we see that
the sponsored URLs are clustered right
in the middle in a very nice way and the
non sponsored URLs are surrounding it so
there is a nice separation between the
two we actually took it a bit further
and we
the 5,000 URLs from each class when the
word the model was most confident about
it about its answer and this is what we
got and again we can see clear
separation now it reminded us of
something but we really couldn't put the
finger on what it is but we felt like
it's a good place to stop the training
we're really happy with the results now
great we start at one URL possess enough
information for some classification
tasks right but here it's similar we we
often challenge much harder tasks that
require actually a click stream or a
browsing context rather than one URL so
what we did was take a list of URL or a
window of URLs and actually fed them
into the URL net ignoring now with the
objective function and just taking it as
an embedding machine now we took those
embeddings and we actually fed it into a
sequential model in our case it was an
LST n and now we can actually talk about
predictive analytics and here the
possibilities are endless we can talk
about what's going to be the next
website that the user will will visit it
would in what category that website will
be or if you're interesting in marketing
right if you have a commerce site you
care about the conversion rate what is
the likelihood that after a pattern of
this kind of usage the user will buy
your product subscribe to your page
right so here the possibilities here are
really endless and this is some of the
projects that we are working on and
planning on working on so let's talk
about something that we had in mind
during the training right so we use
bi-directional l's TM because we want to
find dependencies between URLs from both
the past and the future we had a couple
of Constellation we tried a different
number of constellation about what is
the number of URLs in the window that is
needed to generate some insights and of
course tweaking the neural net
parameters of the embedding size K that
we talked about the learning rate and so
on we had also the parameters of the URL
net and lsdm so it's a whole bunch of
hyper parameters to tune so let's just
summarize what we saw here today we saw
that click steering can be
in the language of the digital world and
we saw how we can get insights generate
insights from it
we saw the deep learning techniques can
overcome classical approaches drawbacks
right which is known but now we can see
that it's also applies to the URL world
it really reduces the amount needed by
expert feature engineering we saw how
character level analysis helped us
overcome the infinite victory right the
infinite the infinite vocabulary sorry
and how we can get representation for
new URLs new words that never seen
before and we see the end we saw that
you're on that really provides
meaningful representation of URLs for
various classification tasks and most
all it was fun I think that the data
scientists who have the privilege of
dealing with some really interesting
interesting tasks and I'm really waiting
for the next meetup to show the results
of the predictive analytics and I want
to say thank you to the to the people
worked on this project on a buncha treat
and if cuts and afghani all of it and it
was really nice talking here thank you
everyone for listening and if you have
any questions you are more than welcome
I hope that I didn't talk too fast and
thank you
please okay so she she asked how we are
dealing with non-english characters in
our URLs the characters like Chinese for
example Chinese URLs so that's a great
question and I said and I mentioned it
before we actually are dealing with URLs
in various languages we are dealing with
URLs in Russian and Japanese and so on
and even those are represented by
character by finite set of characters so
the so the character embedding matrix is
this is still something that is
trainable it's not that huge so if we
take that and we took it on on various
languages
it dealt really well because eventually
Russian or Chinese characters embeds
into a specific character ID we used in
English it was 100 tokens so if we
expand it is now 500 characters that
composes URLs in different languages so
it dealt really it actually dealt in a
in a pretty straightforward way we
didn't have to use any additional
information from the URL so it was the
same model eventually but during which
during the the process we tried
different models from RNA analyst TM and
we didn't need attention we try to use
attention but it's only when the window
of the or elles was was big enough to to
exploit that advantage yeah good
questions are yeah yeah super so the
first question was well the second
question was about the 97% accuracy like
the data set is probably skewed so what
we dealt what we did about that and the
first question was remind me the
stabboard embedding so actually I forgot
to mention it so thank you the character
level the third matrix the character
level that look from look on
relationship between characters in the
words this is the one that extracts
representation of sub words I show the
example of the iPhone access right
iPhone access is a new example but
iPhone and iPhone X is not new so this
is how we could deal with the character
level presentation of iPhone right so
iPhone X s representation will not be
that far for my phone XS and so this is
how we use it fast text and so on we
preaching were debating because usually
URLs contains a lot of gibberish and the
97% accuracy it's true we looked also
about different metrics like and area
under the curve the data set Wars was
askew there was like 15% PII is and 85%
non PII is but we saw that but we saw
that the false negatives were the false
negatives ratio will were low so we said
any PII that we have in the data we only
I think we was taken in 0.08 percent of
the time so there were some URLs that we
said there were PII when they were when
they weren't but the opposite didn't
happen and that's actually what's
important for us yeah I agree I agree I
presented a paper this is the this is
their work
I agree like more on the in the end the
idea right but the results were
different the results spoke differently
it was really good accuracy and in the
ratio and the false positive the false
negatives were really low so I do agree
that by summing up especially like that
summation you lose a lot of information
moreover the character level embedding
in the world level embedding sometimes
maybe in different scale so I think that
if you use those you probably lose some
practice show different so they actually
they actually have shown that if you
used both analysis like word level and
character level it's far more superior
than use only one of them so actually it
did work but but I share your concerns
and style 500 shows the prediction yeah
you trained it and it ran yeah yeah the
entire thing the entire architecture is
end to end so the world embedding
matrices the character level embed
matrices and the weights of the entire
convolutional layers and fully connected
leaders are trained jointly so I think
that a lot of deep learning models
especially envision for example like
faster are CNN and so on show that
end-to-end frameworks usually works
better than those it works in two parts
and this is the case also here yeah ok
so we're asking about the difference
between the scale that I said between
the world level embedding and the car -
level embedding it's not it's not that
different but if you sum eight column
vector eight column matrix so it's gonna
be one magnitude more than the numbers
on the world level embedding right let's
say that they're all day evenly they're
all Gaussian distributed between 0 to 1
at first so this will be 10 times bigger
their representation but there wasn't
any larger difference of scale between
the representation of character level
and world level
any more questions I'm really enjoying
standing here so yeah so we had we had
label data set from different kind of
resources that we have that that some of
them some of them are rule-based
heuristics some of them were tagged by
by other mechanism but but we had the
ground the ground truth in hand yeah so
I'm just gonna repeat the question and
the answer did we use any special
embedding for the unknown character the
answer is not and sometimes using zeroes
perform the same as a random random
embedding yeah so okay so the question
was this problem has many ways to tackle
it right so you're around that is just
one of the problems that we are tackling
so why was the difficulties
on the road that we encountered well
well it took some time it took some time
but once we got to the model yeah so I
share with you the link here and you can
see also it's the the source code of
this thing we need to do a lot of
tweaking let's think about the URL and
we need to do we need to do a lot of
tweaking of the parameters order of the
number of the layers of the objective
function right because sometimes we
didn't want to only classify whether the
URL contains PII or not we wanted to
actually rather know where does the PII
in the URL itself like where it's start
and where it ends so it took some times
now before that some heuristics as I
said include the rule based heuristics
so these are often less sophisticated
let's call it witch but actually there
are more time-consuming right because
here we used a deep learning framework
which did the end to end feature
extraction for us so most of the time
went on how to deploy this thing and how
to tweak the parameters and layers and
the number of classes in the end because
the embedding matrices the the
representation of the characters and the
words is explicitly defined by the way
right so PII will get different
embeddings and sponsored link will get
different word embeddings and character
level and usually using one embedding
from one task to the different tasks is
not gonna work it really it really
learns its own field let's say sorry I
hope that answer that it took time and
the but but the end-to-end framework
really helped us extract the features in
a more in a faster way yeah question
what they compared it to under other
benchmarks so the paper they actually
compared it to to you City which is URL
component tokenization which actually
looks and build different diction
for different parts of the URL for the
main so the main domain will get
different embeddings like google calm in
main domain and common just in the URL
will get different embedding some other
techniques like trigrams or backgrounds
that iterating through the URL so if
they actually took all of the expert
features like let's call it and combine
them and this this performance was
better so this this I performs all of
them and I think eight percent accuracy
but actually they measured it by and by
area under the curve so it was some
improvement you have a good question
so thanks and
[Applause]